the pre lockdown versus the during
lockdown look even with shop century
open postcode retail may well be
different again one at a time says ones
burnout ones come in the cat and mouse
boutique they're laying plans a boost in
online sales has just about sustain them
through lockdown but it's been tough
they're excited to reopen but worried
about restrictions people like to touch
me got wallets here they like to check
if it's real leather they like to open
it that's what our customers do they
touch all the clothes so we will have to
teach them without being preachy on
please don't touch the ones unless you
think you're really gonna buy it but
that is going to reduce sales it's a
tricky one to reopen shops must ensure
safety
that will mean reviewing layouts and
reducing numbers to maintain distancing
and regular sanitizing of touch points
like door handles while customer
handling of merchandise will need to be
kept to a minimum which mean fitting
room should be closed and a 72-hour
quarantine of items returned donated or
regularly handled sticking to the rules
in smaller shops is one thing in
shopping centers it's an operation I
think as a center the biggest challenge
would be to make sure that people are
following the guidance you know we've
got a lot of sort Sony's down telling
people to keep left which will get us
our flow around the sensor and if you
get people that don't follow that it's
gonna be quite difficult but if numbers
stay low and shops can't pay leases the
centers themselves are at risk the high
street was already having a tough time
before covet came along but last month
online sales as a proportionable retail
were at an all-time high hardly
surprising during lockdown but the fear
for many is that those habits will hold
and then there's consumer confidence
open markets are set to reopen sooner
and may feel safer for shoppers thank
you go upward
July when government show that
everything is okay at the moment you are
scared I think it's very what people
wear their masks and take their
medication that should be good
you need to because it's putting the
country on stress I press a fixed issue
because that I think they were the
opening schools is out quite quickly as
are so I feel like if they're gonna open
it like everything just calm down now if
the open them again you have a risk of
it rising again sales of jumpers and
jewelry fund jobs Jude may bring some
relief but many retailers are still
holding their breath I think we'll be
okay but by December who knows
Helen Anne Smith Sky News